daily wire investigative reporter to
resign citing inflammatory statements on
transgenderism I'll give you the quick
version this is Christina buttons of the
daily wire announced she was resigning
because Matt Walsh was mean and that due
to his inflammatory comments on about
Dylan Mulvaney there were people who
were good people and not gender
ideologues who are trans who are
receiving a lot of heat from this and
getting attacked and thus Christina
button's argument is you've got to try
and persuade the middle and convince
them to come over whereas Matt Walsh's
argument to you is you have to humiliate
and denounce and belittle your political
enemies this is interesting because uh I
completely understand the argument from
Christina buttons but I'm going to go
ahead and side with Matt Walsh on this
one
I've been doing this for too long I've
been in politics my whole life cultural
politics like activism and stuff like
that and I used to work for non-profits
and I learned a long time ago this is 13
years ago
man maybe even longer than that 14.
they're all lying these people are evil
people at these non-profits these big
ngos they claim to be big
environmentalists they're lying to
people for money they will claim that
they'll say things like oh our our poor
homeless shelter is filled to the brim
with homeless people and we need money
from you so that we can expand and then
you actually go and look it's completely
empty and they say well no one really
wants to be here because you can't take
drugs when you're in the homeless
shelter so we just tell people that I'm
this is the kind of thing that they pull
off plus you need six figure salaries
for every board member well I mean I
mean the people at the top are getting
paid fat cash depending on the size of
the nonprofit and so Matt Walsh comes
out and says you know we've got to be
mean to the people who are committing
these problems I don't think anyone's
saying be mean to trans people
necessarily there's I take it as a
reference to corrupt individuals who are
evil so previously in the show we were
talking about on the left you have
predominantly evil people who know
they're lying and ignorant people or
people who lack the ability to better
understand people being take advantage
of more or less we want to denounce and
be mean to those evil people
otherwise I see stories like this and it
makes me think this is why we lose
because we just played a video of people
ransacking a a restaurant in Queens we
just played a video uh uh I played a
video this morning of 150 antifa
storming into a government facility
firebombing construction equipment
the left Rules by fear and violence and
the right can't even manage to say a
naughty word
you know I don't want I think it's
better to not not to be mean to evil
people but to control them so that they
do what you want them to do like they're
mob mentality so it's easy to manipulate
them and it's you're better off being
kind and then them trusting you so that
you can control them here's the thing
how do you control Nancy Pelosi
become friends with her grandson I don't
know you get through the family you know
you get to connect them on a familial
level
for real yeah that's how you win culture
I mean let's be honest you make a song
that manipulates people to sing and clap
and like it's all manipulation
I don't know about that I mean
manipulation is not necessarily evil
manipulation is just moving things
around with your hands it's it's
controlling and manipulating society and
people and behaviors and machines and
all that stuff I think it's a fair point
for for me and we want to manipulate the
culture in a positive direction that's
absolutely that's fine but I think I
think some of what you're saying at
least a central theme in my opinion of
what you're saying the reason this is
the way it is is because the left no
matter their differences they always
unify hardcore on whatever is their line
of effort or their messaging campaign
for the week the month the year
conservatives Republicans whatever you
want to call them on the other side
don't we are always a divisive faction
even when we know
what everyone else in our group is
saying is correct for some reason we
have a personal Petty difference with
them and they go out and launch in in
even bigger opposition than the radical
left does let me show you the story from
the New York Post
New York Magazine art critic Jerry saltz
calls for shunning friends and family
who vote GOP so let's compare and
contrast the two articles in one a
report of the daily wire says I refuse
to work at a place where they're mean I
quit and then on the other hand you've
got the New York Magazine critics saying
shun your friends and family if they
vote in ways you that that you're
opposed to you see the difference in the
in in the culture War here yep you know
so when Matt Walsh comes out and the the
meanest that Matt Walsh was we said you
are you are Eerie and pitiable and
unearthly you look plastic I'm like he
didn't cuss
it was just kind of like
a slow downward description of an
individual it was it was insulting but
it wasn't the most insulting thing he
would not win a rap battle by that
nobody would be shocked you know but it
was mean right
meanwhile so so you you've got tons of
people who are critical of Matt Walsh to
varying degrees for being mean for
saying this yeah Matt Walsh said you are
Eerie you are off-putting when people
look at you they will see something
pitiable and plastic and it was like
that's how he said it and that that's
unacceptable the right will not accept
that I won't allow that that talk is
mean meanwhile the left is like
you firebomb a police car and the judge
says you're a good dude that lawyer who
fired on the car the cop was like well I
know you're a good person at heart so
you know we're gonna give you a slap on
the rest here yeah or if you're a la
you're a lawyer in the FBI and you're
anything but pro-trump you can go lie to
a federal judge be convicted as a felon
not go to prison and get your legal
license back who's that who are we
talking about Kevin kleinsmith yeah
yeah he he altered the email right the
the yeah oh yeah real quick for those
that don't know the critical email when
I was doing the Russian gate
investigation was Carter page is a
Russian asset sounds really sexy and be
like oh man we really got to follow this
guy well it turns out the FBI knew the
entire time that Carter page was helping
the FBI and the CIA productively not
being spied on and the lawyer at the FBI
Kevin kleinsmith literally took a
document and changed the verbiage and
then gave it to a federal judge saying I
need a warrant Carter page is a bad man
but we have all this evidence of him
actually helping the United States of
America do you guys remember all those
stories that we've seen over the past
few years where a liberal has announced
that they're leaving the left because of
antifa firebombing police vehicles tons
of antifa being like I will not be
antifa I can't believe they were saying
those mean things those conservatives
yeah it happens all the time right yeah
terrorists I I remember that viral video
of the anti-foot guy he comes out and he
goes I didn't realize they were going to
be firebombing buildings the so the joke
obviously is that that's never going to
happen it's never going to happen there
are it's a pipe dream there are liberals
who are like I was never really involved
but now that I see what they're doing I
don't want to be involved in that but
you don't typically see although it
happens sometimes but you you don't see
a circumstance in which an antifa guy
shelter to an anti-foc rally and then
leaves saying I didn't realize they were
going to throw Molotov cocktails they're
they're down for it they're all down for
it so what do you think the
justification of the reasoning is say I
don't know if you saw this but the
Russell Brand clip on um Bill Maher was
it Bill Maher yes whatever it was or he
basically blasted
we talked about this a couple times he's
wrong Russell Brand is completely wrong
I I should say completely wrong it's a
little a little heavy he's mostly wrong
he's partly right he said MSNBC is like
the same as Fox News they're just as
biased News Guard rates Fox News as
credible but pretty with caution and
they rate MSNBC as crackpot BS
okay so when you get an independent news
agency that's like the New York Times is
the Bastion of Journalism the gray lady
and ABC News and CBS and the Washington
Post are 100 certified and MSNBC is
crackpot nonsense don't trust them and
Fox News is okay and it speaks to your
point or it speaks to the broader point
that we're making when Russell Brand
just saying this is looked at as serious
pushback when you and yet at the same
time when you look at the actual facts
like News Guard and stuff like that it's
like well maybe maybe he they aren't the
same but just the pushback that Russell
gave is enough for people to be like
yeah man he's right because it's so
skewed the challenges are
you know I understand the idea of saying
MSNBC is like Fox News because I've I've
said similar things to friends and
family alike if you know somebody who
watches MSNBC use newsguard show them
that they say it's fake news conspiracy
and dismiss them as conspiracy theorists
and and and equate them with what they
associate as conspiracy so I I was
talking to a friend and they were like
my family only watches MSNBC I can't
talk to them about any of this stuff and
I said next time you're you're over
there
just say something like I don't watch
this conspiracy stuff I don't know you
guys this is weird stuff and then when
they say what do you mean it's news be
like wait The Alex Jones stuff like is
that what you're watching equate them
with what they dislike they will so they
can understand what you're accusing them
of doing and then when you're like well
I don't know what he does isn't that
what he's he's not on that one no look
then you can pull up News Guard and say
see look it says your fake news uh you
guys you you got to understand this
right so I understand the argument from
Russell or I should say in favor of
Russell's statement that for people who
think Fox News is completely fake
garbage nonsense you're equating what
they do with what they view as fake
garbage nonsense maybe then you can step
them in the right direction towards
actually watching Fox and realizing you
know 95 of Fox News is really boring
straightforward news and the only
complaints the left has is like Hannity
and Ingram well they really don't like
Tucker for sure but that's just because
he's influential but it's like the the
opinion stuff they take issue with the
news reporting at Fox News is news MSNBC
doesn't have news reporting it's all
it's all narrative it's all it's all
exactly what the narrative the the DNC
and the left want to put so that's what
it is so I think from a from an honest
perspective
any objective view of Fox News would not
equate it with MSNBC
so that's where he's wrong I agree with
you on that but the fact that guys like
him and Bill Maher are actually going
out there and basically taking a
sledgehammer to a piece of the radical
left-wing agenda for putting out the
dumb narratives that they put out I
think is a step in the right direction
whether they're never going to go all
the way because they're going to come
out and see Fox News is the greatest or
whatever conservative republication is
amazing but at least they're calling out
their own bozos thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time